so oh no a kubernetes is if not you'll
learn we have a nice one-on-one track
today that will teach you a lot of
kubernetes from the ground up but i'm
gonna do is try to talk about kubernetes
in the way you should be thinking about
it so I wrote this guy called kubernetes
the hard way so that everyone can learn
how to do kubernetes ok there is a big
difference from installing kubernetes
and using kubernetes chances are you're
not on both sides and we've come a long
way
raise your hand if you believe
installing crew Bernays is easy what
that's like 7 hands here's my first demo
I'm hoping it works I think it's gotten
to the point where it's so easy that you
can ask for a cluster ok so we're gonna
try this see if you can just ask for a
cluster and see if it will appear
fingers crossed
say one for the demo gods so we're gonna
try this now want send me a DM or
anything to interrupt the flow Stratus
okay go go talk to kubernetes
engine sure here's the test version of
kubernetes engine good day create
kubernetes cluster how many nodes shall
I provision 8 creating a 8 node
kubernetes cluster in the S West one
region that's what I call kubernetes the
easy way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you mean alright so if this
today is not hard anymore what's hard is
that collection of hardware that you
have one print okay that's not our fault
you got to figure that one out so the
next thing we want to talk about is once
you have a curb or a nice cluster again
our goal is not to use ku CTL for
everything that we want to do so what I
like to see people doing people ask me
all the time Kelsie what is the best
practice for running kubernetes in
production the truth is there are some
known patterns but I'm not quite sure
everything is super mature and set in
stone where we can go off and just have
a complete list of best practices you do
this and you're good so what I like to
think about is separate clusters based
on your organization structure if you
work in the enterprise and you have to
open a ticket to get a deployment you
probably need to have separate clusters
for each of your environments trust me
it will be easier that way do not go
down the are back rabbit hole if you
don't have to but as a developer how
many people are developers in the crowd
are you looking forward to getting your
nice coop CTL installed on your laptop
no you see that ops people no one cares
as a developer you have probably one
flow in mind everything else is noise
okay so I have this registry or they
have this app it's called hello world
complex I know and as a developer this
is how you envision the world okay and
it's all of its perfection you want to
clone a repo not install kubernetes is
not your first step that comes to mind
I'm going to clone the repo that I'll be
developing against we'll do this here
we'll go to my laptop and I'm going to
do git clone amazing internet works
all right and then as a developer you
want your actions to trigger something
else to happen ideally if I make a code
change all I want is a URL to tell me
where it's running you get bonus points
if you give me metrics that tell me how
well it's running so the next thing we
want to do here is create a branch so
we'll say git checkout will create a
branch called
change message so we're gonna change it
from hello world to something else so
when I come here and we're just going to
edit this app go is the best programming
language in the world I'm not biased at
all yes you can clap for that hell yeah
all the PHP people like no it's not it's
okay all right so we're gonna change the
message and we'll look at the different
ract between the developer is how to
build this application and what the
dependencies are that's what the
developer owns and that's okay contract
to provide and that's where the docker
file comes in sweet those are the only
things I care about my source code might
docker file everything else is
implementation detail or should be so
once we have this we'll commit it so git
commit always use helpful messages like
change message oh yeah who does this one
do you hate when people do this would
you add so you got your message and now
we're going to push it so remember we
have this branch get push or gin and
then we're going to push this branch
okay so at this point what do you expect
to happen you know switch the coop CTL
write some yeah Mille
lots of people like that sweet yeah
Mille nobody wants to write ya Mille
what you expect is when this gets
checked into a branch that it should be
somewhere ready for me to test in a
staging environment so we go to I'm
gonna just go here so we can see some of
the implementation details
if I hit let's look at our bill pipeline
how many people have intend continuous
delivery bill pipelines damn we should
have had a continuous delivery track
because I think once you get to
kubernetes this is the next holy grail
that you have to do at some point this
is going to be table stakes I think it
already is but this is where you really
should be focusing your time big time so
here's this bill pipeline and have a few
rules based on a developer's intentions
one is if I push to any branches set for
master based on this regular expression
I want to deploy to the station
environment if I tagged it then we want
to go to QA and we'll build a container
image based on that tag and propagate it
to production that is the goal now some
of you're like where's the mo files
where's the deployment descriptor
implementation detail folks
no one cares or shouldn't so now we go
here and we look at our bill history so
I push through this branch and we see
just now a bill completed and succeeded
it built an image with this particular
commit so this is the commit of the
repository so the developer can chase it
back to see how was built and then if we
go to our pods and I hit refresh we see
we have our app in the staging
environment now you don't actually have
to show this to anyone
ideally you should have a URL that maps
to this running application there's no
need to use coups ETL to figure out what
the IP is anyone ever heard of this
thing called DNS always we if you've
never used it
people have reinvented DNS all the time
like what are you doing that's DNS I
know it's not as a distributed service
discovery DNS what you have in it again
this week so we see our changes live so
what happened here let's not worry about
it quite yet so once it's in staging the
next thing I want to do is maybe it
looks right to me I'm going to merge
this I'm gonna tag a release hopefully
your tagging releases and not building
docker containers on your laptop if you
are being shame and then change your
behavior alright so the next thing to do
as a developer is I'm going to check out
master and then I'm going to merge in
the change message branch everything
looks good here and now I'm going to
push it or gen master this is the
experience when you adopt all these
tools that you should be after do not
leak your implementation details into
the developer workflow you don't have to
once I push this change nothing should
happen because I haven't done the thing
to trigger everyone at once what do I
need to do to trigger the next step tag
a release so we're going to tag this
release get tagged 1.0 get push origin
tags
so now that I've tagged this release my
workflow I assume at some point if the
bill passes and the test pass that it
should end up wherever you tell me QA is
I don't care where it is give me a URL
if you give me a URL we'll come here and
we know we need to go through our build
pipeline so we'll take a peek at that so
if we go to images really quickly and
we'll see down here in the hello world
we see that right now our build is still
probably going and when it's done what
we should see is
one dino tagged here and if that's
successful we should see that deployed
to the next environment I'm impatient so
I'm going to hit refresh as if it's
going to go faster
it probably won't let's look at the bill
history so let's see what it's doing
we'll take a peek into the bill pipeline
so what I'm doing now is checking out
the repository grabbing the tag and then
I'm actually using qu CTL to actually
check out my mo file from a separate git
repository that actually holds my
kubernetes deployment structure for that
entire environment now the nice thing
about this is that you can actually have
multiple teams work on those kubernetes
configs independently of the pipeline
and what i'm doing in this case is i'm
checking out the infrastructure
repository and I'm using the coop CTL
patch command to patch the one container
image that I'm concerned with and I'll
issue a commit to the infrastructure
repository I want a history for all of
these things so if this works out well I
can go to my QA infrastructure
repository and see now we have a new
commit if I look at that new commit what
we'll see here is the change that I
expect all right and again no one needs
to see this repository but it's a good
place to actually track all the changes
that you do whether it's a human doing
the change or CI CD system doing the
change so once this is in place where do
you now expect the deployment to be
let's try it with just a URL without
looking at anything else so we come here
and we'll go back to DNS and then we'll
just hit queuing
so it looks like it's working and we'll
verify the deployment here hit refresh
and it's there now there's a missing
piece here if you don't want people
asking for coop CTL again then you got
to give them visibility they can't just
be flying blind here that's when people
start asking for access again so you got
to give them more tools now anyone
notice anything hidden in my deployments
I'm going to show you something here ku
CTL get pods as I'm going to show you
the functionality that I get first so
I'm going to go here and I have Griffin
are running over a proxy and I'm gonna
show you what value looks like right we
get caught so much in the tools that
sometimes we forget about the actual
value that they bring what you want to
do is give people visibility one way of
doing that is to give them a curated
dashboard that gives them insight into
what's actually happening so this is my
QA dashboard and ideally if someone were
to hit the cue a URL maybe they're doing
some testing you got to put those Sleeps
oh we need curl actually okay so now
we're hitting the actual application
maybe you're running some integration
tests so ideally if you give people
visibility they will stop asking for
tools like KU CTL to do their job
because now they can actually just kind
of observe what's actually happening in
the cluster so in addition to metrics
you probably want logs HTTP traces the
more visibility or tools that you give
to people the less they're gonna
probably want to touch the
infrastructure right and that frees you
up to actually upgrade it move it around
without people getting attached to where
it's actually running so once everything
looks good in production what do we
expect to happen now not everyone can
deploy straight to production this is
why I don't like to show these into n
pipelines where you go straight to
production anyone ever had an outage in
production what does the developer say
it was a small change but everything is
down not my fault man
so you might want to put that manual
check in there just to say what's
actually happening so let's take a look
and see what's going on so in my case I
need to trust but verify so what I'm
doing in the last stage of my pipeline
I'm just going to issue a pull request
from the bill system the bill system
will also propose changes to the
infrastructure so that the team can
understand what's actually happening
until we get a little bit more
comfortable with the system so in this
case I'm proposing a commit message by
this system that I want to change this
particular container image to this tag
the same one that's used in QA a lot of
people get confused about this one do
not rebuild the container image between
environments that defeats the whole
point of testing and QA but maybe
between stage and s you're kind of
prototyping and figuring things out
review the change looks good one dot o
and then now what I want to do here is
review it looks good to me
rebase and merge confirm and you guessed
it if I do that what do you expect it to
be you expect it to be in production so
we'll look at the last part of the bill
pipeline so we'll come back here and as
soon as I merge into the master branch
whether I was doing it as a human maybe
I want to change the entire structure of
the deployment config maybe I want to
update the service type that's
underneath there again all of that is
subtracted away from the developer
because what I'm doing now is I'm taking
all of my infrastructure stuff and I'm
put it in this one directory structure
and what you can do is coups ETL apply
recursively and everything underneath
the kubernetes directory it will just
apply again including the changes that
you've made from the CI CD system that
are just concerning the app so that
means your services ingress all your
deployments if they're all combined and
that way you can actually stop messing
with this thing once you start to get to
a stable point where you're not changing
your configs as much anymore
now what tools should you use the magic
of figs go to some sessions there's ten
of them tons of them there's helm
there's case on it there are many of
these tools that will make it much
easier than couch ETL patch to manage
these things so once you all have this
in up and running the last thing that
you think about is how do I actually do
other changes without going to the pipe
you need an easy way to break the glass
right you can't have everyone there
maybe emergencies that you need to sized
up the process at some point you'll
notice one thing here as I wrap up is
that in our infrastructure directory
when you look at my deployment config
you'll notice one thing missing
I don't include the replica count if I
don't hard-code the replica count here
I'm free to use an auto scaler okay
side by side or you can use some other
system within the infrastructure to do
this so we're going to see how we can
actually integrate a last system to see
what this looks like once we get
everything working so we're going to do
is look at the number of pods in
production and see what it looks like
when another system comes up on top so
here we'll say while true get the pods
context production so if you're new to
kubernetes you can actually use coop CTL
when you have to and if you do it
actually does support multiple clusters
go away ciri all right we see we have
one pod running and since the replicas
count is not included in my config we'll
do our last bit to see if we can
actually have multiple systems interact
with the cluster because kubernetes
maintains the cluster state so we have
multiple actors interacting with these
configs at the same time so here we go
we're gonna try this last thing demo
guys have been on my side so far okay
google talk to kubernetes engine okay
let's get the test version of kubernetes
engine greetings
scale the hello world deployment how
many replicas would you like you crazy
break everything ten scaling the hello
world deployment to ten replicas
thank you I gotta admit that was pretty
dope and with that I would like to end
the presentation thank you
[Applause]
[Music]